chess in the 21st century I thought
about showing you a game between like
some super grandmaster 2750 27 plus I
had some some examples in mind but I
decided to show you one of the games I
played in the recent millionaire just
open that has just finished maybe a few
weeks ago because I can I can also
explain you some of the psychological
aspects of professional play so this is
a game between me and a grandmaster from
Venezuela I think he might be the only
Grandmaster of Venezuela very strong
26:50 iturriaga this was in round I
believe round five I was doing quite
well I was three and a half out of four
so my tournament situation was very good
he's as well but he was one of the
favorites I had to continue getting good
results in order to maintain my chances
so this was the second game of the day
keep in mind that I didn't have a lot of
time to prepare theoretically right so I
had some problems because of that
let's let's get into it before Knight f6
c4 e6 Knight f3 b6 okay how do we call
this
anybody knows this is the Queen's Indian
defense I believe yeah pretty easy
g3 Bishop e7 there is also the move
Bishop to a6 which looks to provoke b3
and only after he will play Bishop d7
trying to claim that this move b3 is the
weakness of course after Bishop a6 there
are also a lot of other continuations
for example Queen b3 which is one thing
that I play from time to time queen a4
and also night b d2 so there's plenty
plenty of nuances of the opening that
you guys should know but he played
Bishop e7 this is the main line main
Queen's Indian defense we should be
Bishop g2 c5 this is already a move that
surprised me I try to prepare against
Bishop e7 which is the main line and and
the main line goes something like this
Knight c3 what is fighting what is white
fighting for in this type of positions
what is he trying to trying to get any
ideas yes yes he's trying to get the
center by playing efore right so if you
would have another move
he would play what move let's say it
would be White's turn
rocky one prepares
efore but it allows the defense against
e4 which is 94 so white would play Queen
c2 getting control of the e4 square and
then it would be very difficult for
black to to stop to stop you from take
taking full control of the center but
obviously it's not White's turn it's
blacks turn so he would play what move
if he plays d5 then it's it's a position
that we usually like to play as white
because we would open up the
fianchettoed Bishop with 95 then the d5
pawn would be pinned and then slowly
slowly we will build on buildin
advantage on the fact that we have more
space than our opponent yeah
so in this position black plays 94 and
afters a move such as let's say Queen c2
he's going to play a 5 and he's going to
have a perfectly playable position yeah
but my opponent decided to try to attack
the center undermine my center
immediately and play the move
c5 what are White's options in this
position
what is white to move though so what are
his options
capturing here is a move but it doesn't
heal Denny any any good results I think
because white black is just going to
take back either with the bishop either
with the pond and then he's going to go
castle and then what move to kind of
free himself up let's say castle castle
and I go something like Knight c3 what
would you play if you were black
D 5 D 5 absolutely break the center and
there's absolutely no reason why white
would be better in this position right
so taking on c5 is not necessarily the
best new if we Castle pretty much the
same thing happens he's going to take on
d4 if we take with the night is going to
exchange and now what defy once again d5
this is kind of the liberation move you
know if you get that then black has
absolutely no problems so we get back to
the drawing board and then the only move
kind of that stands in this position is
Knight c3 the same thing I would take
take with the Queen and then again d5
this is the typical break if I managed
to get this then I equalized at least
equalized with black so we have to do
something more decisive in this position
d5 yes absolutely
d5 we have to play the move d5 now black
takes we gave away a pawn right night h4
is the main line
absolutely night h4 is the main line and
and it would have been the move I would
play if I didn't know I didn't know
anything after that so I didn't have
time to prepare I was completely out of
book but I did remember that analyze
this position maybe five years ago and
I've seen this idea of I think topalov
where he played 95 a very rare move so I
decided to play when you're kind of when
you're not prepared well enough for your
opponent and you feel that you're
getting out preparing the opening you
should try to deviate
as fast as possible maybe you analyzed a
move long time ago
play that one trust your instinct and in
general it's going to work out well
what's the point of 95 besides the fact
that we pin this de-spawn and we're
going to recapture on d5 why is it
different
he played h6 what should we do now
night h3 absolutely and now we see where
is this night having F 4 and then d5
right and then we're going to take we're
going to recapture on d5 with a piece
that's going to keep the d-file open is
going to centralize our night and
obviously it's going to give us a better
better position little did I know
actually my opponent played this game
like three times already I had no idea
about it so and he played in one of the
games he played b5 which is a very sharp
continuation and in the other one he
played what he played in my game which
is Queen c7 what is the point of Queen
c7
very good he's forcing me to take on d5
right he's not willing to accept me
taking with the piece on d5 playing
Knight f4 Knight takes d5 so if you
would play like a normal move let's say
Bishop e7 I would simply play Knight at
four I still have a move I can play
Knight c3 and then I would I can take
with the knight on d5 and this is
perfect for me right I have the d5 semi
open file I'm going to create a lot of
pressure against this pawn on d6 right
bishop the bishop at four Queen d2 rogue
d1 this guy is going to fall at some
point so what he's trying to do is force
me to take back with the pawn on d5 I
had to take with the port d6 in what
opening do we get this type of structure
characterized by these three pawns the
Benoni yes
the Benoni this is the benoni structure
where is this Bishop going on g7 right
only seven to be honest II didn't make
any sense it would be just aiming at his
own porn yeah very very very badly place
so he played g6o
1997 first Castle a six a four and now
g6 let's make a plan with white guys
try to create a five six move plan where
you arrange all your pieces in in their
best place now the question is on what
side are you going to play as white and
on what side is your opponent going to
play yes you're going to try to play on
the kingside absolutely and he's going
to try to play on the Queen side because
he has the majority yeah he has more
points than you so he's going to try to
create a pawn store maybe on the Queen
side the same thing that you're going to
try to do on the Kings side I want you
guys to tell me where do I want my
pieces to be where is this night going
to go f2 very good the knight is going
to go to f2 where is this Bishop going
to go
D - B - that would not sit well with the
bishop on g7 and also whenever you play
b3 I'm going to be able to play c4 and
actually attack attack on the Queen on
the Queen side much easier yeah so you
don't want a week on your Queen side by
playing b3 that's kind of what you're
doing
so this Bishop is going to go somewhere
else
a much more natural move on much more
natural placement if you're going to
have four how are you going to how are
you going to place your knight on f2
obviously if you want to place your
knight on f2 you're going to have to
play f4 first right hmm so we're going
to play a four night - f2 waters Bishop
e3 in front of this pawn
probably not so you want to play for
first you're trying to get as much space
in the center as possible that's where
you have the majority in the center so
you're going to play e4 f4 9f2 Bishop e3
and most probably this rook is going to
go where c1 or d1 sure and this rook is
probably going to go only one the Queen
will worry about it later
as you guys will see I didn't place it
on the right square but yeah this is the
usual plan you put your crooks on on the
middle files on the D file and the
e-file efore f4 912 - which is going to
be a very very good defensive piece and
the bishop on e3 what is blacks plan
he's going to make his usual move Bishop
g7 and then castle what next
rugby 8 sure yeah how is he going to try
to advance his his pawns on the
queenside
c4 Knight c5 very good
and then this Knight on c5 is going to
have a lot of offensive tasks right he's
going to attack the pawn in the center
the e4 pawn he's going to look at these
two squares the square on on d3 and on
b3 so he's going to be a very good piece
let's go along so that we see once I
knew what my plan is I immediately
started making the natural moves right
c4 c4 both players were just making our
very very natural moves which you guys
should strive for as well just play
normal chess but play normal chase
abiding by a plan Bishop e3 95 and now
the question is where will I put my
queen I played Queen c2 is that a good
move or is or can we find something
better maybe
what does black want to put this knife
that was a that was a trap that night
wants to stay there actually but that's
the natural response to say I want to
put it on be three yet that point that
that placement on b3 is is not as strong
as it looks like no the night 175 if
possible so my move in this position
should have been Queen e2 attacking the
c4 pawn now I'm forcing the night to
take a worse square and that is the
square on b3 now I would play your okay
d1 and my position would be perfectly
fine I'm starting to try to play e5
right he 5 and then d6 I did exactly the
same thing but I allow I gave him an
extra temple I played Queen c2
he played rugby a continuing with his
plan Bishop a 8 then b5 before this is a
very dangerous plan once he manages to
push his his beep on my pieces are going
to find it very difficult to to find
placement especially this knight on c3
so I kind of recognized my mistake and I
played Queen e2 but I gave him an extra
tempo a very important extra temple 93r
ok d1 Knight d7 ok
what is the consequence of the move 97
and by consequence I mean what squares
is he living unprotected and what can we
do about that
what options open up for us
sure g4 is is is one squared that he's
giving us but placing the night there
I'm not sure is going to be in our
advantage that night on f2 is is
well-placed right now is defending
something else
you need some water or a good scare
hmm what other squares besides g4 does
he not control anymore
h5 so what can we do about that f5 in
general is not a good move in this type
of positions because you're weakening
this whole complex of dark squares in
the center especially this guy right
he's going to plant a knight on e5 and
this is going to be very very ugly for
white ok strategically very very ugly
so we don't want to allow him to put a
knight on e5 h4 absolutely he's he's not
controlling the h5 Square anymore we
have plenty plenty of pieces around our
King to not worry about the safety of
him so obviously we're going to go h4
we're going to create a pawn storm on
the King side h4 Bishop a8 to be honest
at this point none of us could calculate
all the way through so we were kind of
playing poker were just bluffing we I
was just pushing my pawns he was
preparing to push his pawns none of the
players actually knew what's happening
on the board so I continued and another
thing is try not to lose time when
you're doing this type of things because
in this type of situation you're not
going to find a better alternative yeah
and also you're not going to be able to
see things through all the way to the
end there's no way that's going to
happen so just trust trust your instinct
and play with the initiative right
attack the King b5h takes g6 F takes G
6a takes me 5 8 X b5
what now how can we continue guys
Quincy Quincy for is an option
absolutely Quincy for is one of the
candidate moves the problem with Quincy
for is that I'm just going to push
before and you're starting to have some
troubles with with that Knight and even
if you take this point on g6 you don't
have enough pieces to actually create
any sort of difficulties for me so after
I play Knight b1 or 92 you can just
defend with Knight of fate and now C 3
is coming C 3 C 2 is very difficult to
stop that so queen g4 is not a good move
I actually have to open my way for some
of my pieces to go to get closer to to
his King try to realize which ones of
your pieces are kind of lacking space
right now and how can we improve that
interesting bishop h3 the same I will I
will do the same thing before so I play
d5 again I had no idea what I'm doing in
terms of I mean I felt like this is what
I should be doing but I couldn't
calculate all the way to the end right
but I'm sure he was in the same
situation as I was so he played before
taking only five is pretty bad taking
only five I would play what move d6
absolutely then the Queen goes let's say
to c8 you can simply just take on a
eight take on a eight nine takes b5 the
night goes to c7 you're going to have a
lot of trouble yeah I have a feeling
moves such as Knight d5 work as well
Knight Bishop takes d5 Bishop takes d5
and now somehow I'm going to try to to
attack you wait maybe with Bishop f7 and
Queen g4 put some pressure on g6 I think
I have quite a nice position so he
didn't take only five he played before
what to do now
I have a few options I didn't pick the
right one
well I didn't pick the most precise one
to put it that way it takes d6 is what I
play and it's it keeps an advantage but
I think I had a better move
what is the other supernatural move
Knight c4 right Knight c4d takes e5 and
now
I don't think we should hurry with this
six this is an option and I am pretty
sure it's it's good as well but I think
queen g4 is better queen g4 and he's
starting to have a lot of a lot of
problems because for example if he plays
something like Knight of fate right now
after f5 his he's in a pickle yeah and
this is actually a very common way of
attacking the benoni structure pushing
if I first allowing him to take put a
pawn on e5 and then push f5 because
despite the fact that he won upon his
Bishop is is blocked and also he's not
going to have a square for his for his
other piece for the night
most probably right so after a five
white is almost winning but I didn't
understand that and I I took the
decision of taking on d6 which is which
still maintains an advantage Queen takes
d6 and now I have two options
I played the most obvious one the one
that wins the pawn but once again is not
the best one what are my two options so
stop and think about what could you play
in this position candidate moves once
again 94 is one of them the most obvious
one try to think a little bit outside of
the box try to actually look at all your
options even though they look maybe
ridiculous at first but maybe there is
there's a follow-up that you're missing
Knight b5 rook takes b5 then Quinn takes
c4 and then his his rook and the Knight
are both under attack and he cannot
defend both of them that will give us an
extra pawn right so this is what I play
but once again the less greedy option of
playing 94 would have been better
oops 94 Queen to a6
this is what we discussed after the game
as well and we thought we both thought
that black is doing okay but I think
after after queen g4 knight of fate
f5 white white is breaking through you
know it's going to be very very
difficult to defend as black because you
take take and the other night comes into
play and after Knight f6 Bishop before
everything is coming with temple is
going to be very very difficult for
black to to create a difference right
too many pieces around his King so
unfortunately I didn't take my bluff to
the next level I decided to cash him and
take upon which was not not the best
word not the best way so I played 95
root x b5 Queen takes e4 rock a5 and
Knight to f6
what to do now
he's attacking my d5 pawn right always
look at the consequences okay when you
play a move try to see what are you
leaving behind what squares are you
leaving behind what diagonal is your
opening right so fi this is not the move
actually it's quite a normal move quite
natural d5 is hanging he's going to take
on d5 next month
so to be honest there is not really a
clear way of defending that pawn right
once again we have to look for targets
of our own something that we could
attack ourselves Bishop before I'm going
to take only one root X t1 or root X t1
Bishop takes d5 I don't think why I
don't think black has any problems here
yeah
so something else
queen d3 is an option absolutely but I
think first we have to do something else
so I played Bishop d2 I'm attacking the
before part I'm also opening the route
for my rook maybe plan to work on his
six if possible yeah he played Ruby and
now I
I made quite quite a serious mistake I
lost all my advantage in in pretty much
one move let's try to find the better
way for white and let's take it one step
at a time
the one you mentioned Queen d3 now okay
let's look at Queen d3 black takes on d5
depending in the same time the g6 point
right what now he's tied up his knight
is tied up how could I make how could I
take advantage of that or how would I
try to take advantage of their candidate
moves guys check all of them
and I'm going to give you a hint don't
don't maintain your focus only on one
side of the board try to find routes for
your pieces all over the board try to
find targets that you could be using and
you have to do it fast because the next
move I'm just going to move the Queen
out of the D file and then this Knight
is not no longer going to be pinned so
I'm not going to have any problems if
you let me do that try to look at all
your moves with tempo all your forced
moves 9:24 is absolutely is one of them
the problem with 94 is that he's simply
going to play Queen b6 check I'm going
to have to move down my King and then he
can just retreat the knight to have set
FF 6 4 4 for instance so that's the
thing with moving that Knight from F to
he's such a good defensive night and we
cannot really get him any offensive kind
of ideas we cannot find any ideas for
him Bishop b4 interesting
I haven't taught up this before but it
looks like a normal move what I'm
worried about bishop before is that
maybe I can just simply take your
opponent b2
and now if you take on g6 one more time
if you look at the consequences of the
past few moves
I took your pawn on b2 you no longer
have control over the a3 squares so I
can simply play your ok 3 and then the
g3 pawn will be hanging right and the
problem is okay you ventured with your
bishop to take this kind of
insignificant pawn and you left your
king very very discovered yeah so Bishop
b4 is not a good move hmm I hear some
good ideas from the back rook to a1
what's the point
if his check if he is exchanging the
rooks and I think it's one of his only
options to be honest because well for
once if he goes Ruby five you do one
rook takes a8 rook takes a8 and their
walk on b5 hands right
if he goes rook c5 and you can fork it
with the night yeah so he simply doesn't
have a lot of squares for his pieces he
has to take but after route take c1 what
was the problem his bishop and his
Knight and I'm not really sure what he's
going to do your threat is to do what
rook e8
yeah rook takes the eight and Bishop
takes d5 let's say he goes Bishop d7
hunt him down absolutely
hand the bishop let's say he goes Bishop
c64 okay six right and I think he's in
big big trouble by now yep big big
trouble
yeah absolutely let's say he goes
something like rook da now if you take
on c6 I'm just going to take with the
Queen Bishop d5 would be a very bad move
very bad I mean why would you do that
yeah I'm just going to take with the
Queen you're going to take I'm going to
maybe take with the rook now if you take
on c6 I take all the on d2 so you have
to take on before but from such a big
advantage you had now I'm going to play
Bishop e8 defending the g6 pot and I
have the bishop pair that's going to
compensate for for your extra pawn so
that's not enough we have a much better
move here I think what about Quincy 4
yeah Quincy for you know concentrating
your attack on the pieces that matter so
I think he's lost he cannot defend the
c6 the c6 Bishop I mean he can play rook
c8 but then we just take on c6 and the
same ideas happen yeah and if it takes
to the root we take with the Queen on d5
so this is kind of the sequence I missed
I'm I saw Queen d3 but then up but then
after Knight d5 I didn't see row K 1 it
just escaped my my vision so I played
the move f5 your idea yeah I was trying
to be tricky but it's not working so he
took on d5
Bishop takes d5 Queen takes d5 kind of
normal moves I also had I was
maybe two minutes by this moment and
there was no increment there was only
delay so I was I was feeling quite down
to be honest because I had the feeling I
am
I'm almost winning the whole game I had
the feeling I'm going to checkmate the
guy the whole game and then suddenly
after I was very happy I finally got a
pawn he immediately took it back and
with dividends right now I'm my pieces
are much worse place than his he's are
much more active so he took I had to put
the brakes and try to find equality here
what to do let's take some practical
decisions guys imagine yourself having
two minutes on the clock
what are you going to try to do simplify
consolidate simplify as much as possible
yeah but you're not going to try to to
complicate the game right to give away
options to your opponent and what I mean
by options is you don't want to give
this pawn to your opponent because if it
gets a free pawn with with two minutes
on the on the clock you're going to have
troubles stopping that from promoting so
instead of taking on g6 which would have
been a pretty bad mistake because after
Bishop b2 I'm not completely lost but
the position is getting very very
complicated because of this point so I
decided instead of that I will try to I
will give the f5 point but defend might
be to pawn right so I play 93 take what
now
play critical moves guys pose threats
immediate threats hmm Luke f1 of course
can he move the knight to defend the f5
pole no because then the beaver pond is
remains defenseless so his idea was to
play Bishop before king 2h 193 Bishop
takes to e3 Bishop takes to e3 he's
still upon up yeah
continue playing critical moves once
again try to simplify the position as
much as possible and you have to do that
fast
by creating threats so I think ro K 1 is
a bit too slow for example if you go row
K 1 I can also play route d5 for once
but I think I'm going to exchange this
take and play something like b3 right
now you're a pawn down but more
importantly also this this pawn fixed
your opponent the dark Square and it's
going to be much easier for my bishop to
to capture that yeah I think you're all
almost lost here so Rho K 1 is not a
good move something else try to find a
variation in which you equalize the
material Rudy one absolutely where is
the bishop going
he went to g5 okay I don't know can you
can you tell me any other move I'm not
sure if there is any other move but the
problem with Bishop d4 is that I'm going
to go rook here everything with temple
then he has to play what Rudy five van
den Broek f1
how can he defend the f5 point he cannot
he can play Roca faith but then he
leaves the beef for pawn defense
defenseless so if he moves the bishop to
attract to attack my knight then I would
again take the b4 point soba shop before
is not he played Bishop g5 what now
raakhi five very good rook takes e5
Knight takes e5 rook to be five okay
what to do now guys now it's time to
calculate
can we take on f5 that's the question
maybe is not an answer
definitely not an answer
and by the way I reached my 40th move so
I was able to calculate at this point I
was happy
why not
welcome to take the part
hmm Bishop f6 I'm going to take the
bishop with the rook
so rook takes a5 Bishop f6 I'm going to
take rook takes f6 okay so let's say you
go first of all if you play rook at five
King g7 then I can simply go rook f7 and
then go back there's there's a different
critical line that I had to calculate
there we go yes continue Bishop c1
because you're attacking the pawn
Bishop C 1 B 3 and the point of that
variation is what Bishop to b2 so let's
look at that
attacking tonight I lost my knight right
no I didn't because I can play 96 or
Knight c6 both of them work they're
exactly the same thing so the point is
rook takes f5 and what's my plan now
let's say he goes here
93 95 a 93 95 96 before no matter what
he does he plays he plays Bishop c3
you're still going to give the knife
because it's the wrong Scott collar
Bishop right so after that that's just
equal
that's just drop you go here Park okay
take it take it
you know drop this is just a drop right
so actually I can now the question is he
takes on f5 he goes f3 he goes b3 sorry
what would you know how do i untie well
he went he went b3 so that he can play
his idea is to play one Bishop c1 take
my pawn on b2 and then just promote so
what to do there we go
it's not rocket science it's not rocket
science
g4 absolutely very normal move yeah rook
d5 Knight c4 and right now it's just I'm
going to give one of the pawns but I'm
going to take the b3 pawn I'm going to
exchange the b3 pond and that's going to
be enough so he played room d1
kingi to root d4 what should I do now
let's try to be precise because if we're
not he's going to he's going to maintain
some sort of advantage and maybe manage
to win so we have a few options to jump
with that night maybe defend the night
who knows
what should we do 95 absolutely rocked
HD for King f3 Ruby for
where is the plan where is the plan yes
there is a plan so King a 595 sorry
rotates g4 King f3 and now he's playing
room before defending this little pond
this last hope yes of course
Ruth d5 roof d3 rule takes b3 or night
XB 3 can he stop that
nope he cannot stop that he cannot stop
that so he played Bishop f6 I played
rugby 3 he took on b2 I took and we
shook hands for a draw because we were
friends no we're not friends we're
buddies
we're buddies huh he's an extra point
but even if I give you after we exchange
the rooks even if I give you my knight
for free I'm still going to be a it's
still going to be a draw it's a complete
draw yeah and and you're not going to
tell me that this end game is winning
for black right I hope you're not going
to tell me that you lost it with white
shame on you but that's ok sometimes it
happens you should not lose it with like
one second on the clock
ok so thanks thanks for watching this
was chest in the 21st century
you